apple has issued an emergency software
update
after a flaw was found which allows
certain spyware to infect some products
including the iphone and the mac without
the user having to click through on
anything uh sky's jameima walker is here
to tell us more and remember i have to
say i got my ios updated this morning so
i'm fully protected why have i had to do
that
yeah apple has moved quite quickly to
install this emergency software update
to block this zero click spyware where
you don't even need to click on a link
in an email for example in order for it
to be installed on your phone and the
spyware was first discovered by
independent researchers at the
university of toronto citizen lab who
said they have seen zero click spyware
before but it's the first time they've
been able to capture it in order to
really work out exactly how it works
they said they saw it installed on the
phone of a saudi activist and that they
have high reason to believe that the
israeli security firm nso group was
behind the attack now interestingly nso
group haven't confirmed or denied it but
what they have done is released a
statement saying that they will continue
to provide intelligence and law
enforcement agencies around the world
with life-saving technologies to fight
terror and crime now apple have been
very clear that most people like you or
i don't need to worry about this attacks
are generally very targeted but it's
embarrassing for the company who build
themselves and who build imessage as one
of the most secure messaging softwares
and this also comes on the same day as
apple prepare to unveil a new iphone and
updates to airpods and apple watch